and i've got some young people working
from my company that have come through
this program uh three or four years ago
and now we're making 75 80 000 a year
[Music]
hello my name is pastor corey brooks and
i'm on the south side of chicago
bringing to you our rooftop revelations
where i'm staying in this tent for 100
days and i'm still here
i'm so excited tonight to have with me a
friend who has been so magnificent in
helping us in all the things that we're
trying to do as it relates to solving
the issues of violence and crime on the
south side of chicago we've been
creating opportunities and
collaborations and partnership and
tonight i want to tell you about what
we're doing to make sure that we create
opportunities on the south side of
chicago right here on old block so mike
marimovic of manhattan mechanical
services has been working with us and i
want him to tell you about some programs
that we've been doing to make sure that
we
work on the issues that are at hand
giving these kids an opportunity
alternatives and options so mike welcome
tonight to
our rooftop revelations thank you pastor
thank you for the opportunity it's a
nice night up here tonight last time i
was here was very cold out
but i'm involved with the contractors
group called associated builders and
contractors uh we're a merit shop
contracting group
and i met pastor about five years ago
and there's a huge shortage of craftsmen
in the construction industry
and we thought there would be an
opportunity to train young people from
the community
put them through a 10 to 12 week boot
camp and then get them jobs when they're
done with their boot camp unlike a
government program where they train
young people but don't have a job at the
end our contractor community is involved
with training on use of small tools big
emphasis on safety carpentry skills
electrical skills and then when they
complete they have a job and i've got
some young people working from my
company that have come through this
program uh three or four years ago and
now we're making 75 80 000 a year so
these opportunities are a great way out
of a difficult situation here absolutely
it's a great way out of a difficult
situation we've trained over 150 people
uh in construction trades and the reason
why is because one
the construction field is wide open so
it gives us a chance to take these urban
kids out of gangs
out of bad situations
and give them
a skill set that will last forever and
the partnership that we created and
uh the collaboration that we've created
is something that needs to be modeled
and that's reason why we need to build
this center uh so that we can build
capacity and we'll be able to do greater
work we've uh created 150 jobs in the
last three and a half years we could be
creating 150 to 250 jobs a year if we
have this center built and put the
training facility inside of it well
as always you know i thank you for
helping us out and thank you for being
committed to our calls and uh let's
continue to train people for the
construction trades and get them to work
and changing their lives
yeah good luck to your pastor we got 74
days to go you'll make it i'll be back
you